hey do you want to go down to the beach
and we'll both roller skate with a rope
in between us until we get so much
centrifugal force that we fly into
billboards yeah but can I do like a
sweet grind first of course you can but
if any humans kama run gushers
commercials where all the kids head
turned into kuru and then exploded no
one was concerned nobody lies nobody
died making funny faces was such a big
deal back then hate the man make funny
faces the man hates funny faces this
pop-tarts spinning through the vacuum of
space is incredible what is this part
where a plane flies around an apple it's
part of a well-balanced breakfast are
you talking about I never eat airplanes
for breakfast this is the girl from The
OC as a kid that's not Mischa Barton no
way plain daylight no one's at the beach
hard to believe Capri Sun he's like Alex
Mack who stranger the billboard walking
through a fence is like the coolest
thing you could ever do
oh my god he is a demon in there parents
were so nervous that kids were just
having sex and doing drugs but these
kids are just like I'm hungry for cereal
kids dressed so cool back then they
always have like a bike helmet on for no
reason this kid is dressed like the
Fresh Prince of bel-air eiseley you you
I kind of love him he's not not cute but
he's also terrifying
I love well they always add like the
toast with the one thing of butter and
milk and orange juice come on mom
raccoon looking for food in the winter
wait is that oh it's gonna be a
snowboard unit hahaha oh my god god damn
animal cruelty what's that movie with
Arnold Schwarzenegger and his eyes burst
out of his head
twins note for 9000
man that's what rad dudes looked like I
want to be a rad dude what I think about
like why I love the 90 so much I just
think about watching TV I think these
commercials promote and the fact that
it's super cool to be a kid
I definitely got enough of a nostalgic
dose just watching these kids like
Google and I know it and it's cool goofy
book great
I'm big in gooey bull but I just don't
buy it as much anymore I make it now